ほんじゃあ社長の夏野菜や決定してますか野球もちろんそれはね国民的なスポーツです
からねや聞いてパッとというものがあるんですけどもこれで基本的にはやけをします
ピッチャーがボールを投げるとそう
それをこのパッドで打って遠くへ飛ばすは一つ勝つ
ちょっと違うファンだけど自慢センサーで今日はでちょっと行っキーのバットで美音の
パットっていうのがあるんでしょ
ナットのここらへんがゴムでなんか出来てて打つとすっごい飛んで組んで打つかって
ことはすごかったんですよね普通のかってずっとぶっこむちゃんと当たればダメダメ
美音のパターンで使ってるニャ今回も美音のバットを超えるもっと吹っ飛ぶ最強の場
を作ろうというわけで今回はは後のこんな1機の分解ました
待って待ってちょっと想像発売くらい儲かったんだけどこれはちょっとバットだね
パッドだけに
入っていけるですね小銭箱のイチロー分準備したので今回はそのバッドがここにロンド
バスみたいにたくさんゴムをつけていきますいろんなバットが気にならないくらいの
威力色々と思うんで5キロヴァンガードもをつけた最強はバッドの弾力性を生かして
後世に
後に頑張っとり高専求人馬鹿にするなって言うんです地元のクラブ9谷勝具合の滝ルー
プってに入りたいと思います
[音楽]
もっとやっぱり目指そうメジャーリーガーを目指したいという
うわぁこれやべーな
引っ張ればいいですかはぁ
んじゃないですかねあっはいこれちょっと待って本当には
[音楽]
と言ったらいいはぁ
00分岐阜
[音楽]
ああああああああ
ん
うううう
パッん
ちょっとまだ持っているつかね色は業務を全部やろう
car
ok ana
古賀あそこ作曲
おっしゃー北3月のを待ってる月ありました
ああ
これねスイスエロいっす1ティガもうおかしくなっちゃうくらいって見ながらこの
マッドを使って果たして普通のバンドと比べてどれだけで飛ぶのかっていうので
ちょっと実際に打ってみようと思いますうんん
山力がもうかなりラバ陰謀編でやばいこれはるって普通のバットで打っており確実に
ホームラン率は高いんですけどもうちょっと気持ちを動いて来なくえないっすよなか
にも来ていっ
ん javari 思い
ふざけ後期楽にホームラン飛ばせるかをちょっと実験やってみたいと思います生活
[音楽]
yeah
ああああああ
いやはい
もう売っ入ってくれちゃうん
ええええええ
も支援者ホッ
花ん
[音楽]
ん
打ち上がった打ち上がったゲッター
ファイルべっだーいうのじゃないこれ
すごいん
ん
うわっ今アウトスワップ
じゃありません
ソジンバーン試合中にあるまず聞こえなかった
んおお図るくるさん
ます重い重い想い
ん
20ん
なんだ
劣化していってます色が白くなっていってます
な思いだけかもしれないうてる気がするんだけどなぁ
[音楽]
ripe 車両をがいい
ミゲルは送るこれ
ああああああ
[音楽]
ん
これん
[音楽]
あっはっは
ていた
[音楽]
ha
pame
tee
それじゃああーん
パーンッ
んね
おっ
[音楽]
ん
あ
[音楽]
ジャックですねー
晴れなぁそう
いいえ
me
あっはっ
4つがーだーっ
入った